the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu ok let's get started so what
I'm going to do next is switch gears to
one existing compiler which is the
streamit paralyzing compiler so the main
idea bot stream it is the need for a
common machine language so what you want
to do normally is in the language you
want to represent architecture come on
architecture property so you get good
performance you don't do with very high
level abstraction so you based lot of
cycles leading in the abstraction but
you would abstract out the differences
between machines to get the portability
otherwise you are going to just do
assembly for hacking for one machine and
also you can't have these two complex
because typical programmer cannot deal
with very complex things that we ask
them to do and see and Fortran was a
really nice assembly language a common
SME language for imperative languages
running on a unique or machines ok and
the problem is this this type of
language is not a good common language
for multi-core because it doesn't deal
with first of all multiple course and as
we keep change number of course you cut
you it's for example automatic
parallelizing compilers are not good to
basically get really good paralyzed
amount of that even though we talked
about that still a lot of work has to be
done in there so what's the correct
abstraction if you have multi-core
machines so current offering what you
guys are doing is things like OpenMP MPI
type stuff ok you are hand hacking the
parallelism well they show with that
this is X it's basically this explicit
parallel construction of added to
language like C that's what we were
working on and what this does is all
these nice property is about
composability malleability debug
portability all those things were kind
of out of the window and this is why
this paralyzing is hard because all
these things makes life very difficult
for the programmer and it's a huge
additional program burden the programmer
has to introduce parallelism correctness
optimization is all live to the
programmer so what the program has to do
in this kind of world what you are doing
right now you have to feed all the
government ID decisions if things are
too small you might get too much
communication if you are too large you
might not get good load balancing stuff
like that and you need to deal with all
the load balancing decisions all those
decisions are left for you guys unit
figure watch local what's not and if you
make a wrong decision it can cost you
all the synchronization and all the pain
and suffering that comes from making
wrong decisions and things like race
conditions and deadlox and stuff like
that and this while MIT students can
hack it you can't go and treat the dough
programmer to convert from running
writing nice simple java application
code to dealing with all these
complexities so this is what kind of led
to our research for last five years to
do streaming and what you want to do is
move bunch of these decisions to the
compiler granularity load balancing
locality and synchronization those
patients and today's talk I am going to
talk to you about how to write a stream
it program as bill pointed out what the
nice parallel properties how do you
actually go about getting this kind of
parallels and so in streaming in summary
basically have regular repetitive
computation in these filters and this is
called a synchronous dataflow model
because we know at compile time exactly
how the data moves how much each produce
and consumes and this has natural
parallel semin expose exactly what's
going to happen to the compiler and
compiler can do a lot of powerful
transformations as we point by ASL I
point out the first thing
it's because of synchronous dataflow we
know at compile time exactly who need to
do what when and that really helps
transform it's not like everything
happened runtime dynamically so what
does that mean so what that means is so
each filter knows exactly how much to
push and pop that's referred to
execution and so what we can do is we
can come to the static schedule that can
be repeated multiple times so let me
tell you a little bit over what a static
schedule means you assume this filter
push us to this filter puffs three but
pushes one that builds up pops too so
these are kind of rate mismatch it's not
everybody producing consuming ones so
what's the schedule so you can say okay
at the beginning air produces two items
but I can't consume that because I need
three items and then I do two of them
and I can consume the first three and I
and then produce one there and I have
two left behind I do one more that and
now I got three and it consumes that and
produces that and then I can fire see so
the neat thing about this is when I
started there's nothing inside any of
these buffers and if I ran a Bab see
there's nothing inside buffers again so
what I have is I am back to the starting
position and if I repeat this millions
of times I keep the computation running
nicely without no buffers accumulating
or anything like that so I can come up
with this very nice schedule that say
here's what i have to do i write i have
run a actually three times B twice and
see once in this order and if I do that
I my computation keep running and that
gives me a good global view on on what
can i paralyzed what can I load balance
all those things because things doesn't
change one more additional thing about
stream it is we can look at more
elements than I am consuming question
you can actually produce a static
schedule like that lot of DSP code has
very is very common ok a lot of bsp code
right now that goes into hardware
and software they I mean they have very
common property but even things that are
not common what has a very large chunk
of the program has this static property
and there are some few places that has
dynamic properly so it's like can you
write a normal program you do not write
a branch instruction after every
instruction we have a few hundred
instructions and a branch a few tens of
instructions and a branch type thing so
what you can think about it is that that
instructions that without a branch can
get optimized the hell out of them and
then you do branch dynamically so you
can think about like this week what's
the largest chunks you can find that you
don't have this uncertainty on till
runtime and you can optimize the hell
out of it and then you can deal with
this runtime issues a basically branches
so control for changes or dare at a rate
changes at runtime so if you get if we
have 1090 role if you get ninety percent
of the things are in a nice thing and if
you get good performance on that hey it
has a big impact so in our language you
can deal with dynamism but our analysis
is basically trying to find the largest
static shock and analyze so most of the
time that basically said we start with
mt and entries empty but trouble is lot
of times we actually look beyond the
number of we consume so what you have to
do is kind of do initial schedule that
you don't start with empty you basically
consume something you start with
something like this so the next time and
something comes three things come into
the into this one I can actually pick
forward pop3 so so you go through first
thing kind of priming everything with
the amount of net on either and then you
go to the steady state schedule this
kind of give you a feel for what you get
this is the neat thing I know exactly
what's going on in here so now how do i
run this parallels if it's something
actually a roderick pointed out before
their arty types of parallelism we can
deal with so here's my stream
programming here and i do some filters
cat I grader in here the first sight of
parallelism a task parallelism what that
means if the programmer said there are
three things that can run parallely
before
join them together so this is a
programmer specified parallelism and and
you have a nice data parallel nice
representation the second part is data
parallelism what that means is here some
of these things that does not depend on
the previous one of that one so there's
no indication dependence across multiple
indications these are called stateless
filters there is no state that keep
changing if state keep change you had
waited the previous one finishes to run
the next one so if you have a stateless
filter assume that is there a parallel
what you can do is you can basically
take that replicate it many many times
and when the data comes parallely center
table data and it will compute and
parallel get out here the final thing is
pipeline parallelism so you can feed
this one into this one this one into
this one and then doused across in a
pipeline passion and you can get
multiple things execution so we have
these three types of parallels I mean
here and the interesting thing is if you
have state full filters you can't run
this data peril you have two lonely
parallel Sam you can get its pipeline
parents so traditionally task
parallelism is forgoing parallelism that
that you guys had do it right now data
parallelism is loop parallelism and
pipeline parallelism mainly was done in
hardware if you have done something like
Verilog or VHDL you will do a lot of
pipeline parallelism so kind of
combining these three ideas from
different communities all into one
because I think program can have each
part in there so then now how do you go
and exploit this how do you go take
advantage of that so I will talk a
little bit of baseline techniques and
then talk about what stream it compiler
does today so assume I have program like
this nice thing is there are two tasks
in here program are given you don't have
to worry anything about that and what
you can do is assign them into a
different course and run it mean and so
you can think what a for joint parallels
you come here before you do this thing
and you join in here so the interesting
thing is if you have a two course part
of
to XP lapping this one this is unique
because there are two things in me and
the problem is how about if you have a
lot more different number of course and
oh if next generation has double number
of course and I am stuck with the
program you wrote for the current
generation so this is not that great
image game so we ran it on the row
processor we have it has a 16 course in
there that that we have been building
and this is circular simulate of that
but you find Mia is this bunch of stream
it programs we have we kind of get
performance like basically close to two
because that's the kind of parallelism
people have written in fact some
programs even slowed down in there
because what happens in here is the
parallel cement synchronization is not
match with the target because it matches
the program because you wrote a program
because you parallelism in there was
what you thought was the right for the
algorithm you never had we didn't want
you to give any consideration to the
machine you are running and it didn't
match the machine basically if we just
got the parallels and you just don't do
that way so one thing we have noticed
for a lot of streaming program to our
education is there lot of data
parallelism in fact in this filter in
this program what you can do is you can
find data parallel filters and paralyze
them so you can take each filter run it
on every Co for a while get the data
back go to the next field right on every
Co while get buried back so what you can
do is if you have for course in here you
can eat replicate all this for type run
these four for a while and then these
for these for these for these four okay
so that's a nice way to do that so the
nice thing about doing that is you are a
lot of nice into load balancing because
each i doing the same amount of work for
a while and after you accumulate enough
data you go to the next one due for a
while teknion like that and each group
basically occupy the entire machine you
just go down this Grove like that and so
we're at it Suns even slower why
should have a lot more perilous and
who's all those filters were dead a
parallel so he stood up getting stuck it
to now we can easily run a parallelism
of 60 because each other parallel so you
can just put any amount in there but we
are running slow yeah I mainly be
communication ahead because what happens
is you run this for a small amount of
time you have to send it all over the
place collect it back against in it all
over the place collect it back again the
problem is there's too much
synchronization and communication every
person at then it's like this global
barrier and that the data has to go go
shuffling around and that doesn't help
so the other part what you can do in
baseline is particular I'd where
pipeline what that means is you can
actually do pipeline parallelism the way
you can do that is you can look at the
amount of work each filters contained
and you can combine them together in a
way that the number of filters is going
to be just above the number of tiles
available okay so in most program has
more filters than number of course
number of course so will you combine
filters together sir number of filters
is just either same or one or two less
than number of course available in a way
that you combine them so each of them
will probably have a close to the same
amount of work the problem is if you
knew combine is very hard to get the
same amount of work and if you have
assumed eight course you can do this
combination you can say hi if I do this
combination I have one two three four
five six seven eight course i can get
seven of them hopefully each of them
have same amount of work and i can run
that and and then we assign this to one
field and say you on this one you write
it forever you get the data from guy who
owns this one and for any producer it
mr. and if you have more course you can
actually keep doing some of that if you
have enough filters you can each combine
them and do that so we perform we got
this not that bad
so what might be the problems here
yes I'm vocality make sure that the
communicating filters are close
attention yeah that we can deal locality
what's what's not the problem doesn't we
go
lower parel serious problem because the
problem is you're combining different
types of things together and you're
hoping that each chunk you get combined
together will have almost identical
amount of work and that's very hard to
achieve most of the time because the
dynamic it keeps things keep changing
and the nice thing one loops is most of
time if you have Lupo step if you
replicated many times the co is the same
amount of code same amount of work it
nicely balances out hard getting combine
different things become actually how
much harder so again paralyzer man singh
crisis is not really much to battalion
so the streamit compiler right now due
to three things it cause i will go to
detail its course on the granularity of
things so if you what happens is if we
have small field as it combines them
together to feel get the large stateless
areas it dead or paralyzed when possible
and it do software pipe right this
pipeline parallelism I will go through
all these things in detail and you can
get about in about 11 x speed up by
doing all those things so course on the
stream graph so you can look at the
stream drop and say we remain I have
bunch of data parallel apart and before
and what I did is I get a parallel paths
with 16 me and then came or get together
when 16 we came together when 16 me why
I have put too much communication can i
combine data parallel things into one
gigantic unit when possible of course
you don't want to come by and data
parallel part with a non data parallel
paths then entire thing becomes
sequential and that's not helpful so in
here what you found is these four cannot
be combined because if you combine the
minute they become the entire thing
becomes sequential so what you have to
do is you can combine this way so this
all those these are data file all those
things are data parallel and years even
though they are data parallel if you
combine them they become non datapower
because this is actually doing peaking
is looking at more than one and so it
looking at somebody else's iterations
were so you can't combine them so what
the benefits of doing this is you reduce
global communication basically
and the next thing is you want data
paralyzed in 24 course and this one you
can fish for is there but the
interesting thing is when you go in this
one you realize hey there's some task
parallelism okay they are me know there
are two tasks that have that has the
same same amount of work you Mia so
fishing this formation fishing this
force and giving entire machine to this
one is giving entire machine to this one
might not be the best idea what you want
to do is you want to fish it to is and
then basically give the entire machine
to both of these all of these running at
the same time because they have load
balance because they're same thing
repeated and you can do the same thing
in here okay so that's what this is the
compiler do that much automatically and
it reduces its preferred stocks
parallelism so if you are task
parallelism you don't need the thing
about that is the parallelism you need
you do not need to mcdonalds we have
parallel seem to make the Machine heavy
if you have too much parallelism you end
up in other problems like
synchronization so this gives me enough
parallelism to keep the entire machine
happy but not too much and by doing that
actually we get pretty good performance
there are few cases where this pipe this
harder palace of winds out these two but
most of the day actually this last one
we can recover doing pretty well so
what's left here is so this is good
parallelism but and low synchronization
but there's one thing we are doing data
parallelism there are places we are
there are filters that cannot be
parallelized they are stateful filters k
so you can make it London data
parallelism and according to um de lo
that's actually going to basically kill
you because that's just waiting there
and you can't do too much so I'm going
to show that using this separate program
so this number is amount of work that
each of them has to do so this actually
lot of work a lot of this new little
work in each of these filters so if you
look at that these are data parallel but
it doesn't do any much work if
paralyzing this doesn't you help
where are stressed is not then these are
data parallel and this actually do
enough work actually we can go and say I
am replicating this for time and I am
okay I am going to actually good
performance in here now what you have is
a program like this and so if you are
not doing anything else if that we have
data parallelism in so what happens is
the first cycle you run these two and
then you run their apparel this one and
then you run these and then you run the
data para this one okay and if you look
at that what happens is we have bunch of
holes in here because at that point when
you are running that part of the program
there's not an apparel so when you only
have two things in there and run in this
you can run these task parallelism in
here but there's nothing else you can do
it me and and so you get basically 21
time step each five minutes basically
run the entire program but here we can
do better what you can do is you can
take and try to move that there and and
kind of compress there okay but the
interesting thing is these things are
not data parallel so how do I do that so
the way to do that is taking advantage
of pipeline parallelism so what you can
do is you can take this filter in here
since each filters each of the entire
graph is can run only sequential is this
has run after this we can look at the
filter store in separated like that and
kind of say instead of running this and
they sell this why don't I run these
iterations of this one these iterations
of this invocation these situations of
this one and this iterations on the next
one and i am still maintaining because
when i am running this even though the i
am not running entering data parallel
this one's already done previously so i
can actually use that value and so i can
maintain that a dependency but i am
running things from the different
iterations and so what i need to do is I
need to kind of do a prologue to kind of
set everything up in there and then I
can I can do that and I don't have any
kind of dependence among these things so
now what I can do is I can basically
take these two and basically layout
anything anywhere
in those groups because they are in
different iterations and and and disease
i am pipelining this i do not have any
dependence and so i end up in this kind
of a thing and then basically much
compressive and by doing that what you
actually get is really nice performance
and only place that that this actually
wins harder pipelining and this little
bit in there but the rest you get a
really good good win here okay so what
this does is basically now we got a
program that when the programmer never
thought anything about what the hardware
is this road just abstract graph in the
end streaming and given raw we
automatically actually mapped into it
and figure out what the right balance
right communication right
synchronization and got really good
performance and you're getting something
like 11 x performance if you do high
hand if you work hard power you can do a
little bit better this is good because
you don't have to do anything the killer
thing is now i can probably take this
set of programs which we are actually
working on is you can take them to cell
which has depending on the day 6 core 7
ko's eight goals and we can basically
get to the matching the number of course
in there so this is really so the right
now what happens is you have to
basically hand code all those things and
this can automate all that process so
thats ideas can you do this which we
haven't really proven this is our
research right once using email so right
this program once in this abstract way
you know I really don't think about full
parallels you have to think about some
model parallelism what how this can be
put it into a stream graph but you are
not dealing with synchronization and
load balancing performance you don't
have deal with that and then the compile
I will automatically do all these things
behind you and get really good
performance and the reason I did this
show this was basically one mostly I
think yeah best show this was it's not a
simple thing the compile actually has do
bunch of work the work that used to do
before things like figuring out what's
the right Garrity what's the right mix
of operations what type of trial
some nations you need to do to get there
and but at some point we can do we do
maybe three things cause plane data
parallel and software pipelining and by
doing these three we can actually get a
really good performance in most of
programs we have so what we are hoping
is basically these kind of techniques
can in fact help programmers to get
multi core performance without really
going and dealing in the grunge level of
details you guys do you guys will
appreciate that and hopefully you think
of making because now at the end of this
class you will know all the pain and
suffering the programmers go through to
get there and the interesting thing
would be to in fact look at the ways to
basically reduce that pain and suffering
so that is why I hot i have today and so
this was a as i promised a short lecture
the second one any questions the same
yeah okay so if you do that how does it
scale up sand as higher communication
constant all be so got all over here by
doing this the software pipelining you
have to do all of your communications
off time so the interesting they are
right now is we haven't done any kind of
hardware pipeline we are kind of doing
everybody's getting lot of dead the neat
thing about right now is even with a
speed in him cell and even draw the
number of tiles are still small enough
that a lot of communication unless you
do way too much command it doesn't
really overwhelm you because you can
everybody's nearby you can send things
they talked a little bit about in cell
that near neighbor nurse helps but
doesn't not that much but as we go into
larger and larger course it's going to
be a become an issue you near neighbors
become much easier to communicate and
you can't do global things in there and
at that point you will actually do some
hardware pipeline you can't just do
assume that at some point everybody
going to get some day it and go to
something so what you need to do is have
different chunks that only communication
would be between these chunks would be
kind of pipeline communication so you
don't you don't mix later round so so as
we go into larger and larger course you
need to go start doing in in techniques
like that the interesting thing here is
even though what you have to change is
the compiler hopefully the program stays
the same you right now it's not each
issue because our compile has ten times
more code than the programs we see it in
the program but if you look at some
flexi the code base is millions times
larger than the size of the compiler so
at some point there will be switched
it's easier to stain the compiler to
kind of keep up-to-date that's what
happened in CS every generation you
change the compile you don't ask
programs like Orion application so can
you make these kind of things as just as
the multi course become different bigger
have different features you change the
compiler to get the performance but has
the same code base that's the goal
that's the goal for portability
we try to find streaming or the
streaming model in general to codes that
are not explicitly or not not very
clearly stream-based but rather but
using the streaming model to make the
communication explicit such as like
scientific codes or for example the
kinds of parallelizable loops that you
cover in the first half electric some of
those things if we need reform simple
communication can happen to streaming so
for example what we are done doing is
things like right now MPEG some part of
the MPEG is nightly stream it but when
you're doing when you actually go inside
the MPEG are dealing with the frame it's
basically a nice big array and you're
doing that so how do you chunk if I the
race and basically deal with it in the
streaming and there's some interesting
things you can do there are obvious some
stuff that doesn't fit that bill so
assume things like kind of pattern
recognition type stuff we have what you
want to do is you want to assume you are
trying to good example you are trying to
feature recognition in a video I mean
what happens the number of features can
you might recognize two features we
might check in a thousand features and
then each feature you need to do some
processing and that is a very dynamic
thing and that doesn't really fit into
streaming order right now and so the
interesting thing is the problem we have
been doing is we are trying to fit
everything into one so right now the
object oriented model is it basically
everything has to fit in there but what
you're finding is there are many pieces
that doesn't really fit nicely and you
do this very crazy looking things just
to get every program to fit into object
oriented model that doesn't deliver I
think the right way to work is is there
might be multiple wonder if there's a
streaming model there's some kind of
threaded model there might be different
one so I don't know what other models
the key thing is if program might have a
large chunk in one model another chunk
in mother don't try to come up with
right now what we have is we have a
kitchen sink type of wrangling let's try
to support everything else at the same
time and that doesn't really work
because then you have to think about say
ok done can I have a pointer here and
then and my I need to understand to
think about all the possible models kind
of colliding me
having the object oriented model of is
much more general I've to me it's not
the best model for many things but as
much more generalizable than some models
and having a single model cuts down on
the number of semantic barriers you have
to cross I don't know but I semantic
barrier sinker both programmer overhead
and runtime the problem it's right now
is our semantic barriers is object
oriented model plus huge number of
libraries if you want to opengl its
object oriented but you had no the
library if you don't do something as
your interlibrary what the right thing
would be instead of trying to learn the
library learn kind of subset language so
you have nice semantics your nice syntax
in there you have nice error checking a
nice optimization within that syntax
instead of because the trouble is right
now everything is in this gigantic
language and you can't do anything and
in the program you don't even know
because you can mix and match in really
bad base when the mix and match gives
you gives you a lot of power like but it
can actually really hurt and a lot of
people don't need it like for example in
see people dot it was really crucial for
you to access any part of memory
anywhere you want you just can't go and
just access any program anywhere anytime
in there if you look at it nobody takes
advantage in that how many times you
write the programs here I want to access
the other guys were stacked from this
problem you are variable and you use
wherever okay yeah but the thing is bad
because of that power it creates lot of
problems for a compiler because it needs
to prove that you're not doing that
which is hard and also if you make a
mistake the problem is yeah this looks
like right it still matches mice
semantic sense in text I will let you do
that but what your realizes that's
something people just speak with your
variables and if you don't go out of
variables and that's what type safe
languages this it's probably more of a
bug than a feature and the same kind of
thing having teachers in language is you
can do everything at the same time how
can two why can't we have a language
that you can go with this kind of
context i am in the streaming context
now and i say this is my streaming
context I Minister that context I am
then what that does is I had
learn the full set of features but I
restrict what I am using here that can
probably really sing through your
performer programmability because you
don't have to worry about that right now
your glove if you look so messy shop it
has all these features it has trained
new features is saturated features it
has every possible object or a treatment
yes this is a compact central model
which covers most things and then you
can pull in additional features will
amaze you you can do corner manipulation
C sharp but you bracket things with an
unseeded things into an unsafe block and
then the compiler knows in there you're
doing this bad thing but I said can you
do it more than I mean that's that's
nice then because you can have unsafe
but can we have something that this is
my straining okay can I do something
like this so I don't worry about other
the key thing is the way we are right
now my feeling is if you look at the
object oriented part was also if your
blooms from some windows programming you
can spend about week and learn all the
object-oriented concepts your spend
probably year learn all the libraries on
top of that that's where all the action
is these days it's basically building
blocks had become too low and then
everything else is kind of an organized
mess on top of that can we put more
abstraction things that easy i'm down
here I'm talk about Risa this is one one
possible angle I mean their money you
can think of this unauthorized message
the right thing in there because i think
my feeling is is what we have what we do
where is when things get too complicated
we build abstraction layers and the
interesting thing they are is we build
this high level programming language
abstraction layer and then now we have
built so much crud on top of that
without any abstraction layers I think
it's probably time to think through
there could be at the abstraction of
things like it's hitting I mean this is
the parallel is amiss really hitting
because that layer the object-oriented
layer doesn't really suppose that way
and it's all I kind of ad hoc on top of
that and so that says something yes it's
usable it's like yeah I mean we had this
argument with assembly languages
programmers for two decades I mean there
are people who saw him by assembly
language they can they could have write
it in two times smaller two times faster
that anything you can right hilar
language spout still true today but and
then there are things that that
high-level language is one out I mean
acting we are probably in another layer
like I don't know I mean fine we'll go
with that argument can always point
something saying this is something you
cannot do if there are still things like
structured programs unstructured problem
we talked about that that argument went
for a decade can you formulate a kitchen
sink language I parallelizable level of
abstract ha that's interesting because I
parallelization is the one of the
biggest things people have figured out
is compulsory you can't have two
parallel regions as a black box put
together you something got into
deadlocks and all those other issues in
their most of the things that you work
is the abstraction work because then you
can compose at a higher level
abstraction you can have interface and
say here are something interface I don't
know what's underneath I composer the
interface level and then I keep then the
next guy Campos at the higher level that
and everything is here we don't know how
to do that in federalism right now need
to compile two things it just like it
runs into problems and minute you figure
that one out if somebody can figure out
how what's the right abstraction that is
composable parallel abstraction I think
that's that will solve a huge amount of
oil I think what I would say is right
now is a very exciting time because
there's a big problem and nobody knows
for the solution and I think for
industry they'd sleep lot of day loose
lot of sleep over that before i can
email is the best time as we don't care
we don't make money out of these things
we don't have to get the products out of
there but this actually have a very open
problem that a lot of people cares about
and i think this is fun heart in because
of that i think i think this huge open
problem that if you talk to people like
entails and microsoft lot of people
worries a lot about they don't know how
to deal with the future in fight any
ensign they don't see they don't see
this is scaling what they are doing and
from intel point of view they made money
by making moves slow available for
people to use
and they don't know how to make it they
know how to make it available but they
don't want they don't know how to make
people use it from microsoft point of
view they are their current development
methodologies almost at this breaking
point if you look at last time the day
this happen in such things like Windows
3 we are their current developer
methodologies doesn't really scale and
they really revamped it they came up
with all this process and that had
lasted is now for the last two office
and and and Vista just realize they
can't really scale that up so they are
they're already in trouble because they
can't really scale they can write the
next big boys that's two times bigger
than vista and hopefully be working but
on top of that they have been thrown
this this multi core thing and that
really puts huge amount of money so they
are they are worried about that so from
water point of view everybody is
clamoring for a solution and things like
last time round i will talk about this
in the future like last time around when
that happen it period huge amount of
opportunities and bunch of people who
solved it kind of become famous but they
say can we came up with a solution and
then that people start using and stuff
either right now everybody's kind of
waiting for some will come up in like
here's the solution here's a solution
and there are not up in there is a
fortress type approach is one and what
we are doing is one and hopefully some
of you wind up doing something
interesting that that that might solve
it this is why it's fun I think this we
haven't had this much of a interesting
times in in programming languages
parallel Sam architecture in last two
decades so with that I stopped my top
you